31 32 33 34 35 36 today we're going to
make a special video and it's it's
really it's all about athletics and
competition because we know that around
the world in many big competitions like
the Olympics and the World Cup and
things like that lots of athletes and
sportsmen compete to try and be the best
and they compete for prizes and often
those prizes are given in the form of
either gold or a silver or bronze medal
so what I thought we'd do is just take a
look at perhaps the chemistry of gold
silver and bronze and see how they could
how to line up against one another a 51
52 53 54
so before we really look at the
chemistry I thought I'd really do is to
try to show you a couple of samples so
you can see what the metals really look
like so I've got some samples of gold
some silver and bronze for us to have a
look at now then you can't tell anybody
because this sample of gold is actually
my mother asks wedding ring and this is
a piece of Welsh gold and you can see
it's a really quite shiny quite
beautiful piece of gold so Welsh gold is
really quite historical it dates right
the way back to the Romans when they
developed a new technique for mining
called hydraulic mining and there's
still only one gold mine in Wales
producing this gold it's actually used
for the wedding rings of the royal
family as well so it's a really quite
special piece of gold that I'm going to
give to my other off in a few months
time this is a sample of silver and it's
unlike much of the silver that we find
in the jeweler shops throughout the UK
because this piece of silver actually
comes from Ethiopia where it was mined
directly from the soil and then beaten
to the shape of this really quite nice
bangle it's really quite a heavy sample
of silver as well so the third place in
any competition normally gets a bronze
medal and this is a bronze medal that we
found earlier on in our chemistry
department which is normally given to
somebody that comes first and that's
first in the graduating class at our
University so if we take it out we can
see that it's a really nice metallic
coin really quite heavy as well but you
know bronze is different to gold and
silver because bronze isn't actually an
element so if we look out on the
periodic table we won't find bronze
bronze is actually an alloy it's an
alloy of copper and tin so for the sake
of this video we're really going to
treat bronze just like we treat copper
so now I'll show you a piece of copper
and here it's a rather large lump of
copper
it's really quite a soft and malleable
material very expensive as many people
find now and it's generally used to make
water pipes and all sorts of wires and
things like that so we're going to go
and have a look now and see if we can
find that the coinage metals or the
noble metals on the periodic table so
what are the differences or the
fundamental differences between the
coinage metals but actually that it
rolls around the shape and the size of
the nucleus and what can we learn from
the periodic table well if we look we
can see that copper itself has got 29
protons and 35 neutrons as we could down
the group the elements get bigger silver
has 47 protons and a total of 60
neutrons so it's quite considerably
larger now as we go to the bottom of the
group we might expect it to get even
bigger again and this is right so we can
see from the periodic table that gold
has 79 protons and a massive 118
neutrons so it's really really large so
what we're going to do now is we're
going to go outside and we're going to
do a little bit of an experiment that
everyone can do so that you can
visualize and we can compare the
difference between the atomic nature and
sort of nucleus of each of these coinage
metals so what we're going to do now
right is we're going to try and build
ourselves a nucleus now what does the
nucleus look like well nobody really
knows because it's like a mixture of
neutrons and what's the neutron looks
like well nobody really knows because
it's a subatomic particle so today I
just want you to imagine that it's
actually something like a chip-in okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make copper in this beaker so what we
need is 29 protons so here we go ready 1
2 3
bronze is a fantastic thing really
because if you think about it there was
a whole age from 4000 years bc when
bronze was generated in the Far East in
Persia which is now around in Iraq 28:29
so we have 29 protons so here we have
half of the components of our nucleus
now we need to add the neutrons that's
35 of those in copper
one two three
now bronze is an alloy of copper and tin
but if you then adds other elements
perhaps add phosphorus you know a little
bit of perhaps tungsten maybe a little
bit of iron you can generate a whole
range of different materials with
different properties they're all very
hard they're very malleable really
useful to make tools out of and really
that's what's spurned on a lot of sort
of development of our civilizations 3435
so we have twenty nine protons
thirty-five neutrons copper so really
this is just part of the atomic particle
itself because we've got all those 29
protons and they're 29 positive charges
so if we want to use our imagination
again we have to imagine 29 electrons
all whizzing around somewhere around my
head and above and below us which give
us our neutral copper atom so now we
take a bigger beaker and now we're going
to make some silver it's going to rain
so for silver we need 47 protons so at
the Olympics all of the athletes that
are competing they're really striving to
be the best and they're striving to take
home the gold medal but you know gold
might not be the best in terms of
chemistry duck for instance if we think
about conductivity electrical and
thermal conductivity then Silver's the
man that you want because it's got the
highest conduction that we know of any
simple pure elemental sample 46 47 so
there's our 47 protons that are required
for silver nucleus now we have to add 60
neutrons is 2020 you might ask the
question why do we use copper for wires
well we use copper for wires simply
because it's a lot cheaper it's more
abundant in the Earth's crust it's
easier to extract much much much more
useful and much more economical for us
to use so here
47 protons and 60 neutrons let's compare
it to copper
I think you can see that it's quite a
lot larger okay as we get down the group
we come to our favorite the one which
all of the athletes are trying to aspire
to and that's gold so here we have a
larger beaker so that we can make some
gold so to make gold we need 79 protons
and 118 neutrons it could be some time 1
to 12 13 13 14 15 42 43 44 well you know
Gold's really really inert doesn't form
very many chemicals or very many
compounds it's a very very unreactive
material and perhaps it's one of the
reasons why many many of the governments
around the world use gold for the
storage of wealth 77 78 79 79 protons to
make gold so now we need 118 neutrons so
we're all familiar with the term bullion
and Krueger and and it's really
interesting because the most pure gold
samples that you can get actually come
from Canada they're the Canadian maple
and that's 0.9999 percent gold
so it's 99.9999% gold really really pure
many many of the other bullion that are
traded around the world might be 98
percent gold so the other bit that's in
that sample might be something like
copper or nickel or something even as
much as silver copper very famously is
put into gold because it allows us to
generate different colors of gold like
rose gold which is slightly red in
coloration and we might get indium in
there which might give us a nice white
gold look which looks a little bit like
platinum 14 1516 and 17
118 neutrons so there we have gold so
here if we bring all three of our metals
together we can see that as we go down
the periodic table so down the group
from copper through silver to gold that
the atomic size of each of those
particles is getting bigger and bigger
and bigger so now that we've done that
it looks like it's going to rain so
we're going to go inside and then I'm
going to tell you about my special idea
for a new metal so say here's my crazy
idea you know in all competitions medals
are given out bronze silver gold and if
we look at the periodic table we can see
bronze is copper based silver and gold
but you know in the times when many of
these metal conventions were were
established they really didn't have the
bottom of the group number one one one
or roentgenium so do you think it would
be really cool like if the winner of the
Olympic marathon got a medal of
roentgenium well let's think about it
for a moment because rhenium sits here
at the bottom of the group and it's
extremely radioactive it emits very very
quickly in degrades giving our alpha
particles very very quickly in fact the
most stable isotope of rhenium has a
half-life of only 10 minutes
most of those isotopes perhaps about 3
to 5 seconds so you may think receiving
a roentgenium medal might be fantastic
but you wouldn't have it for very long
and my suspicion is that it's probably
not going to be very good for you